it's the largest death row in the United
States most of those sentenced to death
by the state of California and up here
and some of them have been living here
in San Quentin State Prison for decades
a lot of people just here you have
people here 20 30 years both sides of
the capital punishment debates say this
is unacceptable but for different
reasons opponents believe it is inhumane
and the innocent people could be killed
they want proposition 62 to pass which
would replace the death penalty with
life in prison without parole it's a
measure supported by some of those who
suffered most relatives of murder
victims him dying wouldn't bring back my
husband it wouldn't undo all of the
horrible things that I went through and
that my children went through and my
family it wouldn't undo any of that
others by contrast want to speed up the
process of executions they support
proposition 66 which looks to shorten
the time for appeals and put the worst
killers to death sooner to get very
personal about it this for me is about
ensuring that the guy that murdered my
child meets the fate that he deserves
there are nearly 750 death row inmates
in California though the state hasn't
put anyone to death for a decade after
next month that could change with a
faster path to executions or the
complete abolition of death row